Speaker 1: The other element to all of these
conspiracies that we're talking about day
after day after day is the fact that Republican
congresswomen and men are whipping their their
constituencies into a frenzy.
Last night in Williamson County, Tennessee,
which is just miles north of Nashville, there
was a school board meeting.
And at this school board meeting, they had
medical experts testify about their agreement
with their support of children wearing masks
in school.
I'm going to read from the Charlotte Observer
article about the melee that took place, and
I'm going to play a clip of it.
It is.
Saddening, I mean, really, there's no other
there's no other objective, it is it is it
is a sickening moment in American history
right now that we're all living through watching
the mismanagement of this health crisis at
the hands of the Republicans, governors all
over the state, and then also your local municipalities.
The Charlotte Observer, Article A..
Maskers threaten experts over mandate in Tennessee
schools.
We will find you.
The two minute clip, two minute clip I'm getting
ready to play posted on Twitter by journalist
Matt Masters, was recorded at the Williamson
County Administration Complex in Franklin,
Tennessee, after the school board voted in
favor of a temporary mask mandate amid rising
covid-19 cases.
Williamson County is just south of Nashville.
Sorry, I said north.
Hundreds attended the nearly four hour meeting
where 30 people were allowed to speak.
WKRN reported all of this.
The board ultimately passed the measure in
a seven three vote.
Under the new rule, all elementary school
students, staff and visitors will be required
to wear a face covering inside and on busses
starting Thursday.
A notice on the Williamson County website
states the mandate expires September 21.
Eleven fifty nine p.m.
So it is a brief temporary order to wear a
mask.
It's not installing an iron lung and sticking
your kid in it, it's a piece of cloth over
your face that mitigates the transmission
of a deadly virus.
Watch this moment from these maniacs.
Unidentified: John.
For now.
Speaker 1: They are stalking a health official
through the parking lot, telling them to take
his mask off screaming at him.
We will not comply.
It's a mask.
You're a child abuser.
They proclaim now and everybody's taking notes,
but keep it gets worse.
They track around the side of the car and
they start accosting someone in their vehicle
with their window rolled up.
The same knucklehead in the T-shirt.
Saturday in America, cops there doing nothing
for kids stuck in traffic, and we know.
We know.
No more people come, no matter what is getting
ready to take place is an alarming thing because
it's the person who is trying to act as though
they're reasonable.
Keep it calm.
We want peace.
Who immediately starts parroting the same
rhetoric as t shirt guy here?
Turning to the person in the car, explaining
to them, we know who you are, we will find
you.
No, no, they're not.
You're not satisfied.
Yes.
Calm down.
We know we know who you are.
We know.
We know you are lying.
You will never be allowed in public again.
We know who you are.
You can leave freely, but we know who you
are.
We will find you.
And then.
You'll never be able to be in public again.
The same people who were very likely outraged
that a man approached Tucker Carlson in a
fish and tackle shop and said something to
him peacefully, this is a melee.
This is on the verge of violence.
So much so that there has to be cops planted
constantly throughout the crowd, all over
the place.
Watch how this the rest of this unfolds.
I have never met a lot of public service.
Yeah, I know who you were.
Unidentified: You have to watch how do you
Speaker 1: keep it from everybody, back up,
back up, back up, back up, back up, back up
again.
I'm a parent is a wonderful example.
Setting for children, the parents.
Yeah, fantastic.
Fantastic.
This is.
A melee, it is this kind of thought is this
kind of behavior that led and I don't think
it's a stretch, I don't think it's a reach
to draw a line between this type of a lack
of adherence to science and research and data.
And and instead, a belief in conspiracy theories,
I don't think it's untoward to try to link
that to the insurrection that took place.
It is a frame of mind.
All of this is taking place, these hundreds
of people screaming and wailing and gnashing
of teeth.
Over trying to keep kids safe.
Over wearing a piece of cloth over their faces.
Inexplicable